así es un saludo muy especial a liliana
a todas las personas que se conectan a
través de esta señal
el maestro johnny pacheco deja un legado
invaluable porque él es uno de los
grandes arquitectos de ese sonido que la
gente conoce como salsa de toda la
música afroantillana él fue quien
escuchando radios de onda corta por ahí
de las
presentaciones en vivo que escuchaba en
cuba- en los grandes teatros en los
sesentas antes de llegar
a nueva york precisamente tuvo ese
sonido ya desde muy pequeño y llegando a
nueva york precisamente huyendo de como
él lo contaba pues de unas amenazas del
presidente trujillo porque su papá tenía
una banda y la banda sonaba también que
quería el presidente de trujillo que se
llamara a la banda claro está trujillo
para entonces eso logró algunas
enemistades dentro del gobierno y tuvo
que irse a nueva york y ahí fue donde
precisamente encontró la salsa en la
calle lo que le escuchaban los radios y
lo puso en un nivel en el que se volvió
mundialmente
querida y mundialmente apetecida la
salsa se escucha en todo el planeta y
uno de los grandes arquitectos y uno de
los grandes líderes dentro del sonido
paña porque pues él antes de la panne
había hecho algunos álbumes de charanga
junto con xavi y palmieri luego como
solista entonces después de toda esta
construcción de su sonido toda su vida
toda esa es testimonio de migrante y de
personal que es lucha en contra de las
adversidades poniendo la música y un
testimonio de los otros de nosotros como
latinos pues es lo que lo hace a él una
de las personas más importantes y no el
más importante e influyente músico de lo
que conocemos como salsa ahora pues toda
la música cubana y afro antillana puesta
en escena mauro pero ya os hemos contado
un poco pero brevemente cuál es el
legado fundamental por el cual se
recordará a johnny pacheco las próximas
generaciones que van a pensar cuando
escuchen el nombre de johnny pacheco
rápidamente
bueno pues popularmente por la fania
porque es el fenómeno comercial más
y una de sus creaciones más grandes
siento que la gente lo va a recordar más
por eso que por qué por todo lo que en
realidad aporto y pues va a ser bonito
también pues porque hace parte de su
carrera de su historia y es un
testimonio de toda la lucha que tienen
las personas dentro de países que no son
los suyos y encuentran afinidad con sus
culturas y con sus sentimientos así es o
sea que eso lo que va a ser el maestro
pacheco va a ser grande por siempre y un
ejemplo a seguir para siempre que vuele
alto en el cielo